So let's say you've got
some awesome Android
game with hundreds of
thousands of downloads.
But it seems like you can't
break that million-user mark.
The reason?
Users are unhappy with
your game's performance.
You see, users notice
bad performance
before any other
feature in your game--
before your item stats;
or your UI interfaces;
or how, on level three,
one of your characters
is actually speaking Klingon.
And guess what?
Users unhappy with
performance give bad reviews
at a higher percentage than
any other problem in your game.
So you want to break
the million-user mark?
You're going to have to fix
the perf problems in your game.
And for modern
Android games, that
starts with understanding that
there exists a delicate dance--
a tango, if you will-- of
interaction between the CPU
and GPU in your
game that can have
a drastic impact on
your performance.
And the dance works a
little something like this.
Modern graphics APIs don't
allow the CPU to talk directly
to the GPU hardware.
Instead, it uses an
intermediate process
known as a graphics
driver to handle
communication between the two.
Drawing calls from
the CPU are cached
by the driver in
a message queue.
And when the GPU hardware
is ready for work,
it will start consuming
commands from the same resource
and begin executing on them.
The existence of the message
queue process in the driver
means the CPU can
be pushing messages
into the driver at
a different rate
than the GPU is reading from it.
And as such, your GPU can
be consuming, processing,
and drawing data that's
around one to two frames
behind the CPU.
Now, while alarming,
don't worry.
This is actually really
typical of modern hardware
architectures.
But with this in
mind, understand
that hitting 60 frames
a second in your game
requires both your CPU
frame and your GPU frame
to both complete their work
in around 16 milliseconds.
When either of these two
systems starts to go out of sync
and take longer than
that, bad things
happen to your frame rate.
For example, what if
your GPU has more work
to do then your CPU?
This means that your CPU is
going to be submitting frames
into the driver at
a faster frequency
than the GPU is actually
going to be consuming them.
Eventually, the driver queue
is going to get filled.
And any time the CPU wants
to submit a driver call,
it'll have to block,
wait for the GPU
to clear up some
commands in order
to free up space, at which
point the CPU can then carry on
and submit its new commands.
On the other hand,
if you're CPU-bound,
then you're inserting bubbles
into your GPU pipeline.
Every time the CPU
submits a frame,
the GPU will consume it
immediately, process it,
and sit around waiting
for the next frame where
it can do work again.
The straightforward
way to fix this
is to simply do less
work on the CPU.
But in this case, it may
be that the GPU simply
doesn't have enough work to
do and the correct action is
actually to give it
more work in order
to fully maximize
the GPU throughput.
There's a great
opportunity to put
like 200 extra zombies on the
screen for your designers.
You can get a general estimate
of where your problem lies
by taking a good look at your
CPU frame time for a couple
seconds of simulation.
For example, if your CPU frame
time is around 16 milliseconds,
then your game is
running pretty well.
Now, while your goal
is to keep things
under the 16-millisecond mark,
some frames, your CPU load
changes and you expect
slight variances in the time.
If, however, your frame time
starts to spike suddenly
and your CPU computation load
hasn't changed-- you know,
you haven't put 200
zombies on the screen--
then there's a high probability
that this is due to the GPU
getting backed up,
forcing your CPU
time to stall in the driver.
These tall spikes are actually
pretty telling since they're
around 11 to 15
milliseconds of time, which
would be exactly how long the
GPU would need to flush a frame
or so.
In order to figure out
what the culprit really is,
it's time to sit down
and get proficient
with mobile profiling tools.
Some of the nuances
of the GPU performance
require dedicated
tools to discover.
But thankfully, each
Android chip manufacturer
provides a great suite
of tools to give you
more information
on how to optimize
your game for their hardware.
Understanding and optimizing the
dance between the CPU and GPU
is the first step in maximizing
your game's performance, which,
of course, results in
happier users, which
could result in
better transactions.
And that's the
whole point, right?
So keep calm, profile
your code, and as always,
remember perf matters.